all right so i'll grab it uh speaking of  dancing my taco table is about guys who  actually dance when they score  touchdowns players from the green bay  packers uh they're joining one a little  fan with an impromptu tea party check it  out  [Music]  that is awesome right there listen the  training camp practice the monotony of  waking up every day doing the same thing  it'll really get to you your body will  start to fatigue your mind will start to  fatigue but it's fans like this that  make it all worth it the players walk by  and there's nothing in the cupboard  behind the car they just go along with  that and a couple players said oh this  is the best key ever and she just lit  up i think that's so sweet